hey youtubers is Charlie happy day
before the Superbowl I thought it'd be
fun to do Captain America Civil War
video but because there's so much stuff
happening with guardians of the galaxy -
I wanted to do that too so this is gonna
be like a mash-up between those two
things although it's gonna be a while
before we see the Avengers on screen
with the guardians the last big time
they had a crossover like an official
crossover in modern continuity was
during Avengers infinity
during that big miniseries event you see
all the Avengers in space fighting
people that you would normally see the
Guardians fighting that in original sin
are probably the last times that I've
seen a bunch of big crossovers with
space-based franchises original sin is
kind of its own separate thing Avengers
infinity is probably a much better
example that crossover for obvious
reasons fan OHS the mad Titan of the
cosmos his dark quest to rid the
universe of the living have granted him
the use of incredible weapons of great
power but now Fano seeks something more
sinister than ever before the buildings
the ancient massively powerful alien
race that has seeded life throughout the
universe have marked earth for
destruction to save the world the
Avengers must join forces with some
unlikely intergalactic allies and face
the builders in deep space leaving the
birth probable to fellows and his black
board
with the combined record Santos and the
builders the heroes of birth are about
to learn a Harold I guess it's actually
a good idea to do an update on phase
three they've added a couple films
they've switched the order because of
the arrangement they made with Sony and
spider-man so here we go starting with
Captain America's Civil War obviously
that's coming up really soon then next
we have Doctor Strange that's this
November then next spring we have
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 which
I'll be talking a little bit more about
because they just started shooting it
then a couple months after that will be
the first spider-man film in the new
trilogy at Sony then later that year
will be Thor Ragnarok and in February of
2018 Black Panther will drop its film
it'll be doing the Deadpool thing where
they drop a film near Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day with Black Panther
that's not a bad idea then a couple
months after that will be Avengers
infinity War part 1 so Black Panther is
the last film before Avengers infinity
war then a couple months after infinity
War part 1 is ant-man and the wasp and
we're gonna get to see hope Van Dyne
where her wasp costume then Captain
Marvel will be after that the next year
in March then a couple months after
Captain Marvel will be Avengers infinity
War part 2 and then a couple months
after infinity War part 2 will be
Inhumans but just think about it for a
second 11 freakin films in phase 3 that
is a giant DVD boxset
if you include the spider-man film which
I think that they'll try to do just to
boost sales a little bit but what is
Captain America Civil War have to do
with guardians of the galaxy mostly the
crossover is going to be thematic only
think you think about it this way
Captain America Civil War is where the
Avengers tear themselves apart
guardians of the galaxy too is kind of
where the galaxy tears itself apart we
don't really know a whole lot about the
story of guardians of the galaxy too
right now we know that it's going to
address Peter Quill's father it's either
going to be Captain Marvel or starfox
I'll talk about that in a second because
it's actually pretty funny but
essentially all these franchises are
building towards infinity war where the
universe literally rips itself apart so
naturally as you build to that
everything has to spiral out of control
and that's what's going on at Captain
America's Civil War everything just goes
batshit crazy if they're going to be
running the Marvel Bus over any
characters in civil war I hope that they
do not take it back at the end of the
film like I want them to leave
things in this really awful way so that
in whatever next movie they can rebuild
obviously infinity war is probably when
everybody's gonna come back together
everyone's gonna hate each other after
Civil War infinity war is that thing
where everyone's like okay there's this
bigger threat let's put our
problems aside come together to fight
this then you can do the Captain America
Iron Man Rocky 3 end credits scene where
they step into a train to have a
gentlemen Avengers fight to decide who
is the best without any prying eyes let
me know if you guys would actually like
to see a scene like that obviously
that's years and years away because you
have to tear them apart you have to kill
a couple people they need to come
together for infinity war then they have
to step into the ring again like okay
we're cool but that time you beat me a
long time ago that was a sucker punch
that wasn't a fair fight
let's have a fair fight to decide who is
the best badass just to address Captain
America Superbowl stuff don't know
exactly what they're gonna drop it's
probably gonna be a really short TV spot
and then they'll post a longer trailer
online whatever ends up dropping I'll
totally make a video for it because
we're so close to the film they probably
will release new footage that'll explain
a little bit more about what's going on
with the film usually the first couple
of trailers just tease the basic idea
we're all cap wants to do is keep his
friends safe and it leads to this big
rift in the Avengers very very simple
idea for Captain America Civil War
there's a lot of other stuff going on
that's usually what you see in the later
trailer so I'm hoping to see vision show
up and I'm hoping to see more Scarlet
Witch badassery because they've been
teasing that her powers will be off the
charts in this movie stepping up into
space
what's going on with guardians of the
galaxy - James Gunn's been posting some
behind-the-scenes pictures of them doing
rehearsals they're gonna actually be
shooting really soon so there will be a
lot more information about guardians
coming in next couple of months but
what's the story gonna be there's a
number of galactic stories that they
could choose to pick from war of Kings
as a solid pick because it involves a
lot of big galactic factions fighting
with each other even though there are a
lot of characters that they don't have
access to annihilation conquest is
another solid pick that was the original
event involving Ultron and the
annihilators that brought the Guardians
together the reason they became the
guardians of the galaxy so obviously
they changed that a lot for the first
guardians movie they you know a circle
back around and grab some of that stuff
- Ultron of course so whatever the story
actually ends up being it will be a
slightly different version of the comic
book story but I feel like they could
incorporate some of this into the
guardians of the galaxy
to story where you just have a bunch of
galactic powers that have a treaty
someone breaks it so they all go to war
and the Guardians get caught in the
middle but Bunny's Duff Peter Quill's
father who is Peter Quill's father
they're really two solid picks one Star
Fox - Captain Marvel because they're
relatively humanoid they've had
storylines that have overlapped with a
lot of earth-based characters but
they're also relatively powerful cosmic
figures that would fit with the idea of
Peter quill having altered DNA that
would allow him to hold an infinity
stone without it vaporizing him either
character for his father is a solid pick
who there's this weird storyline with
Star Fox in the comics where he's the
sex offender he gets prosecuted for it I
don't know how Marvel would address that
in the movies so they might just
sidestep it it'd make Captain Marvel his
father even in the Marvel Universe being
a sex offender is one of the few crimes
that you could never come back from even
Thanos found some Redemption
during the Infinity relativity storyline
where he saves the universe starfox was
originally known as eros of tightened so
it'd be really awesome if starfox or
Peter Quill's father because he's kind
of Thanos his brother making Thanos
Peter Quill's uncle it'd be this really
crazy family thing
Captain Marvel not Captain Marvel
different character is part Kree
so that would also work because the Kree
is such a big deal on the first
guardians of the galaxy movie let me
know in the comments though between
those two characters who do you think
Peter Quill's father might be
Captain Marvel or starfox and it isn't
necessarily related but it's space-based
I know a lot of you been asking about
the rumors about them doing a version of
Planet Hulk during Thor Ragnarok and
Avengers infinity war the rumor is is
that they're just weave in the Planet
Hulk storylines some broad strokes of
that with Hulk forced to fight in the
arena on a version of Sekar and then
it'll go into more Thor bait story
because it's gonna be a Thor story Hulk
will be a big part of it so that's why
you've been hearing Mark Ruffalo talk
about Hulk getting this mega storyline
spread out over a couple of different
Avengers base films but everybody get
ready for Super Bowl tomorrow there's
going to be a whole bunch of trailers so
I'll be posting more videos than normal
so just keep your eyes peeled for that
you can follow me on Twitter and
Facebook I'll be posting a whole bunch
of trailer related stuff in addition to
the YouTube videos that I do so while
you guys wait for all that stuff to drop
you can click here for all my captain
Civil War videos and you can click here
for my Deadpool kills the Superbowl
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you